MALE SPEAKER: I'm incredibly
excited to be on stage here
introducing Andy Weir, the
author of "The Martian."
I read the book last
year, and it was
my favorite book of all 2014.
And I've lost track of how
many engineer friends I have,
that I respect, who also say
it was their favorite book
of last year.
Andy is the son of a--
ANDY WEIR: What about the
ones you don't respect?
SPEAKER: They-- they think
it was not very good.
Andy is the son of a
particle physicists
and has a background
in computer science.
He began writing 'The
Martian' in 2009,
researching related
material to try
to make the book as
realistic as possible
and based on real technology.
Andy's book is an
extraordinary adventure
about human ingenuity and humor
in the face of great odds.
Although, it falls easily into
the science fiction genre,
it's a book for every one.
It has remained on
Amazon's best seller
list since its
publication last year.
And it was the winner
of the 2015 Audie Award
for best science fiction.
A film version of
the book is actually
coming out in October,
directed by Ridley Scott
and starring Matt Damon
and Jessica Chastain.
Please join me in
giving a Google warm
welcome. to Andy Weir.
ANDY WEIR: Thank you.
Hello.
Hi everybody.
Oh cool, the wander around mike.
Good.
So, I'll just give--
I'll preface this
by saying I threw out
my back this morning.
So, I may have to sit
down during my talk, which
is why they've set
up this chair for me.
That's what I get
for turning 40.
So, I'm going to tell you a
little bit about the story
behind the story,
and then I'll get
into the things you
actually care about,
the details of the movie.
So, I always wanted
to be a writer.
All my life I loved writing.
I loved science fiction.
I grew up with reading
my dad's endless supply
of classic sci-fi,
which is interesting
because he'd grown up
just collecting, kind of,
pulpy sci-fi books.
And, so I ended up reading,
kind of, one generation off.
I Don't think dad ever
thrown away a book.
And he has- he had
a bookshelf that
was about six feet high,
three feet wide, one foot deep
just jam packed
full of sci-fi books
from the '50s '60s and '70s.
So that's what I
grew up reading.
And so my idols are Heinlein,
and Clarke, and Asimov.
And a lot of those
books don't really
stand up today
especially when you
talk about the role
of women in society.
But if you grade
them on a curve,
they're still really good.
Anyway when the time came for
me to choose a college major,
I kind of-- there were
two things I really liked.
I liked writing and I
liked computer programming.
And I wanted to be
a writer, but I also
want to eat regular meals.
And I wanted to live somewhere
other than a box in an alley,
so I decided I'll be
a computer programmer.
So I went into
computer programming.
And I did that for
about 25 years.
Or actually I started
when I was 15,
because I ended up working
for a national lab in town.
I grew up in
Livermore, California.
Woo.
There's a whoo.
Thank you one person.
And, so, I end up working there
as a test tube cleaner lab
assistant guy.
And they said, well, we don't
need you to clean test tubes,
but we need someone to figure
out how to present this data.
There's a computer.
Here's a book on programming.
Come back when you
figured it out.
That began a 25 year career
in computer programming.
Anyway, I went to college.
And I actually dropped out
because I ran out of money,
because that's kind of the
norm for my generation.
And I ended up going into the
computer programming field.
I worked for a couple places.
I was actually one of the
programmers on Warcraft II,
when I worked for Blizzard.
So, yes, you can thank
me for some of those lost
productive hours of your youth.
And then-- and then later
on I worked for AOL.
And I worked for
AOL until 1999, when
I got laid off along with
800 of my closest friends
because they merged
with Netscape.
Yes, that's how
long ago that was.
Now at the time at a
bunch of stock options.
And, so, I was forced to
sell these stock options.
I had 60 days to sell
them or lose them.
So I sold at what turned out
to be AOL's peak price ever.
So I assure you I would not have
made any sort of wise market
decisions if left
to my own devices,
but I was forced to do this.
And I ended up with
a bunch of money.
And I'm like, hey, I've got a
bunch of money, now is my shot.
I can live for a few years
without having a job, which
is good because it was 1999.
All engineers lived a few
years without having a job.
And I'm going to take my
shot at writing, here we go.
I'm going to write a book.
So I took three years
off, and I wrote a book.
And it was not "The Martian."
So, you may wonder why
you haven't heard of it.
It's because it
wasn't very good.
It was actually my second book.
I wrote a book in
college that was
so bad, even I knew it was bad.
And it was before the
era of the internet,
so there are no digital
copies out there.
No one will ever find it.
There's only one physical
copy left that I know,
and my mother has it and
won't tell me where it is.
Because she knows what'll
happen if she does.
The second book,
I did post online.
It was OK.
The plot was decent,
but the prose was awful.
And it's really awkward
to read, but you
know it was my second pancake.
And, so, I had the
standard sad experience
that all struggling
authors have.
Couldn't get an agent.
Couldn't get a
publisher Interested.
Just nobody was interested.
And after three
years no success,
I went back into the
software industry.
Now this wasn't a
huge defeat for me,
because I actually really
like programming computers.
I've always-- I've always
enjoyed that aspect of my job.
And I've always enjoyed the
high salary that comes with it.
But I went back in
the programming.
And around this time,
it's around 2002ish,
and now the-- know the internet
is starting to really creep
up and become more popular.
Everyone's got an
internet connection.
Everyone knows how
to use the web.
And I thought, OK,
so what I'll do
is I'll write stories
for fun and just
post them to a website.
And I can-- that way I can get
an audience reading my stuff.
And I don't need to make
a profession out of this.
It'll just be a hobby.
So that's what I did
for about 10 years.
I made-- I started
out making web comics.
I made a web comic called "Casey
and Andy," back in the day.
And then another one
called "Chesire Crossing."
And then I realized I'm A,
a terrible artist, in and B,
I don't like doing art.
So I went to writing short
fiction or long fiction,
whatever, just
narrative fiction.
And so I spent a lot
of time doing that.
Just posting short stories
and serials to my website.
I wrote one short
story called "The Egg"
that was very popular, and
that brought a lot of people
to my site and helped
build up a mailing list.
And around the time I started
"The Martian," which was just
a serial I was
posting to my website,
I had about maybe
3,000 regular readers.
But they were all science
minded dorks like myself.
And, so, it was kind of cool,
because as I posted chapter
by chapter, I posted a chapter
maybe every six to eight weeks,
they would email
and say, excuse me
you got something
wrong on page 17.
And, so, that was really handy.
It was-- I called
them beta readers.
So that process went
really smoothly.
And it-- but it wasn't
some laser like focus.
It was like sometimes
I'd go months
without posting a chapter.
It took me three years
to write the thing.
And I was working
on other serials
and short stories of the time.
So while I was writing "The
Martian," this hard sci-fi
story about this man
stranded on Mars,
I was also writing a story
about aliens invading earth,
and a story about a mermaid in
the 19th century a New England.
So it's sort of an
eclectic group of stories.
Anyway, so eventually I
finished "The Martian." and.
I thought, OK, I'm done,
moving on with life,
on to other things.
But I started to get email
from people saying, hey.
I really enjoy "The
Martian," but I
hate reading it on your
site, which is fair
because my site is crap.
Can you make an
e-reader version?
So I figured out how to do that.
I made an e-reader version,
an EPUB, and a MOBI.
And I just posted them on the
site, and said there you go.
Then I got another email
from people saying,
hey I love your
story, hate your site.
But I appreciate that
there's an e-reader version,
but I'm not very
technically savvy.
And I don't know how to download
the thing from the internet
and put it on the my e-reader.
So, can you just post it
on Amazon or something.
So I figured how to do that.
And I did it.
And it was pretty easy.
It's KDP, Kindle
Direct Publishing.
There's no initial cost outlay.
You just upload your
thing and you set a price.
But you have to set a
price of at least $0.99,
are not allowed to
give it away for free.
It turns out Amazon
likes to make money.
So, and you get a
percentage the royalties.
And, so, I set the price
at the minimum $0.99,
earning me a cool
$0.30 per copy.
And told everybody all
right-- well, OK so first
off you do that, you
post it, and then they
hold onto it for
about 48 hours to have
an actual human look at it.
Just to make sure you're
not posting a big goat porn
compendium.
Don't judge.
So, then once it's for
sale I posted to everybody.
I said, OK, here you go.
You can read on
my site for free.
You can download the e-reader
version from my site for free.
Or you can pay Amazon a buck
to put it on your Kindle, which
is basically what you're doing.
And more people paid the
buck than anything else.
They really-- it
just goes to show you
the reach that Amazon has
into the readership market,
and that people are
willing to pay a buck
to avoid technical hassles.
So it started to
sell really well.
And it started working its
way up the top sellers list,
in various categories in Amazon.
Got Gone up into the
top 10 of sci-fi.
Got up into number one in
sci-fi, into the top 20
in all Kindle.
And, so, that's
when things really
start to snowball, right.
Because now you've
got people going,
oh, I want to read a book.
I don't know.
Whats-- I feel like sci-fi.
What are the top 10 in sci-fi?
I'll pick one of those.
So you get this--
a lot of exposure
by being on those lists.
And so the sales really
went through the roof.
And I didn't realize
how well they
were selling, because I
had no experience with self
publishing.
I looked at my sales
and I was like, huh,
I'm selling about
500 units a day.
Is that good?
I don't know.
It's self publishing.
It seems like it's good.
I can't tell.
And then-- but
what's funny is when
you submit to KDP you
automatically become
part of this forum, where you
can talk to other authors.
And, so there's this forum
where other authors are
talking about their books and
how to market their books.
And there are threads
where they say,
tell us your sales numbers.
Everybody post
your sales numbers.
And people are like, I
sold five copies today man.
That's awesome.
Hurray for Christmas rush.
And I'm like, I sold 500.
I guess that's pretty good.
So anyway, eventually, I
didn't know this was going on.
But it got the attention
of Random House,
or actually
specifically by Crown.
If you look at your
free copies you'll see
is published by Crown
Publishing, which
is a division of Random House.
And at the time there's an
editor at Random House name
Julian Pavia, and
he was re-- he had
the book recommended to him.
He'd heard about it and he saw
it was doing well on Amazon.
And he thought,
should I read this.
I don't know.
Is it something that would
have mainstream appeal,
or is it just engineer porn.
It's not clear.
And so he said-- he was
talking to a colleague of his,
a literary agent
named David Fugate.
And he said, I'm not sure if
I want to read this or not.
And David said well,
I'll read it and let
you know what I think.
And he's all right.
So David read it
and he liked it.
And he came and said hey,
you want an agent, to me.
And, so, after three
years of not being
able to even-- after three
years of just constant rejection
by agents, now later in life,
I have one knocking at my door.
Which was pretty cool.
And, so, I did some
research on him,
make sure he was a real person.
And then said sure and he's
like-- and he's like alright.
So Julian, how much you going
to pay us for this book.
So he was-- he negotiated
the book deal with Jillian.
And then while
that was going on,
20th Century Fox came
for the film rights,
which is interesting, right.
And those two negotiations
were going on at the same time.
And both of them were--
both negotiations
were completed four days apart.
So that was a very
eventful week for me.
I got a print deal and a
movie deal in one week.
So I was-- I had to take a
day off there just to go home
and lay down.
I was so worked
up, and stressed,
and anxious it was horrible.
I got-- I couldn't breathe.
So anyway, the print
deal came together.
We did some minor
editing on the book,
because of course once
a publisher gets it
they want to make some changes.
But pretty minor in the
grand scheme of things.
No substantive plot changes.
Just hey Andy, you got a little
excited in this section here.
You have people talking
but never tell us
what room they're in
or what's going on.
It's just a bunch of
floating dialogue.
That sort of thing.
And, hey Andy, nobody
anywhere understands
what you were saying in this
paragraph of technical crap,
so simplify it.
And then they released it.
And it was-- in its
first week of sales
went straight to the
best seller list.
So it really did very well.
And at the time
the movie rights--
so the way movie rights
deals work is it's
not just some guy drives
up in a limousine,
hand you a pile of
money, and then they
go make a movie, right.
It's a little more complicated.
So the first thing they do
is they secure the option.
So they're not actually
buying the rights yet.
What they're doing is giving
you a small amount of money
to be the only studio that
is allowed to buy the rights.
So they're securing
the exclusive option
to buy the rights.
So you work out the whole deal.
You work out the whole
rights purchase deal.
It was a 34 page contract that
I had to sign and notarize
in four places.
You work out that
whole deal in advance.
Saying, here's a
big pile of money
we're going to give you
if we buy the rights.
And here's a part the
contract that says
only we can buy the rights.
And here's a small pile
of money that we give you,
so that you're willing to
agree to this option deal.
And so they give you
a small pile of money.
Then they have 18 months
to activate the contract.
And they can just
activate the contract
by sending you the
big pile of money.
And if they don't
activate the contract,
then the rights
devolve back to me,
and I get to keep
that small amount.
So that's how options work.
And they don't activate
until they are absolutely
sure they need to do it, because
it's a fair amount of money
and they don't want
to just piss it away.
So they actually only activated
the rights contract the day
they started filming.
So it's the moment--
and the reason
is because that's
the moment when
they have now generated
intellectual property
based on it.
And they're like, well, now we
need to make sure we own it.
So anyway watching that
process unfold was fascinating,
because I didn't-- at the
beginning everybody told,
they literary agent,
my film agent,
everybody in the
industry told me,
don't get excited about
people buying a movie option.
The studios by several hundred
options for every actual movie
they make.
You have a less than 1%
chance of this actually being
greenlighted.
So don't get worked up.
Just enjoy the money that they
gave you and call it a day.
But then they got
Drew Goddard on board.
Drew Goddard is veteran
screenwriter and director.
He directed "Cabin
in the Woods."
He wrote "Cloverfield"
and a bunch of episodes
of "Lost" and Buffy."
He is the creator and
writer of the new Netflix
"Daredevil" series.
So he's a veteran.
And he really liked the book.
And so he wrote a screenplay.
He said I want to
write and direct this.
So the studio FOX was
like, sure, sounds good.
Write a script and
we'll take a look.
So he wrote a screenplay.
And then he was set
to write and direct.
And they're like, well,
we have a director,
but we need an actor.
We need someone to
take an interest
in playing the lead role.
This movie is not-- we're
not willing to make it
with a nobody in the lead role.
It has to be a big name.
And, so, right
around that time then
Matt Damon expressed
interest in playing the lead.
And, so, the studio
is like, oh really.
And they start taking a
project a lot more seriously.
They're like, OK, now we've
got a veteran director
and a the top tier well
known actor to play the lead.
And then Sony came along
and offered Drew Goddard
the director's chair for
the new "Spiderman" movie.
And he's like, sorry
guys I got to do that.
This is a dream come true.
So he left to go work on that.
But he's like,
enjoy my screenplay.
And that makes it
sound mercenary.
He was-- he's really
invested in a project
and he kept working
on it the whole time,
but he's like I'm
not going to direct.
So, he goes off to direct
the next "Spiderman" movie.
And then-- now the
studio is like, aah.
We had a director and a star.
Well, first we had a
director and no star,
now we have a star no director.
And then Ridley Scott
said, I'll direct it,
and they said, oh really?
So once they have
Ridley Scott on board
to direct and Matt
Damon on board to star
that's pretty much when they
made the decision that they're
definitely going to do this.
Although I didn't know that.
To me it just seemed,
well, this looks good.
And then everything else
started to fall into place.
The studio was like, OK, we are
going to sink a bunch of money
into this.
If we're going to green
light it, we'll go big.
And then, also a bunch of
big name actors and actresses
took an interest in the
project, because it's
Matt Damon and Ridley Scott
in a big budget movie,
and it'll be heavily marketed.
And they like being in
those sorts of things.
So then they started
to get all these really
big name actors and actresses
interested in playing roles
in the movie.
And they were like,
well, this is super,
but there's just no way
we can afford all of you.
There's no way.
If we paid all of
you what you're worth
this movie would cost $400.
Million We can't do it.
And they just-- a lot
of them just agreed
to do it for less than
they would normally
get just because they
really liked the story.
So that's why that
cast is ridiculous.
It stars Matt Damon, Jessica
Chastain, Sebastian Stan,
Kate Mara, missing,
missing one of the crew.
Oh Michael Pena,
and Aksel Hennie,
which most people
don't know him.
Meanwhile on earth,
the roles are
played by Chiwetel
Ejiofor, who you
may know from "12 Years a
Slave," or maybe this crowd
might know him best from the bad
guy from the movie "Serenity."
And Kristen Wiig, Donald
Glover, AKA "Childish Gambino."
Hey, for those of
you under wrap,
you might know him by that
name and not the other one.
Let's see, who else is
on Earth, Jeff Daniels.
Yeah, it just goes on and on.
It's just this ridiculous cast.
I'm sure I missed people too.
But, so, they got this
cast and then, yeah.
They started
shooting in November.
They finished shooting
in March, and now they're
doing post production
and test screening.
The test screenings have
been going very, very well.
The audiences are
really liking it,
so it's looking like it'll
be a really good movie.
And I got to see it on Friday,
just two-- a few days ago.
That's actually
why I'm down here
in Southern California,
because I went to FOX
and I got to watch it.
And I was really psyched because
I get my own title placard.
It's up on the movie, "based
on the novel by Andy Weir,"
and no other text on the screen.
So, now the first
question I always get,
so I'll just go ahead
and pre-answer it now.
Hey Andy, what was your
involvement in the movie?
So I'll go ahead
and answer that now.
My main job on the film
was to cash the check.
I did that very well I feel.
I mean just smoothly.
They didn't have any--
they have no requirement
to involve me in anything.
They don't need to
consult me in any way.
The only thing
that's in my contract
is they're going to give me
money, and then way later on I
get to go to the premiere.
That's it.
They don't need to
consult me at all.
But they chose to involve
me, so that was really cool.
Drew called me a
lot, frequently when
he was writing the screenplay.
He's a super guy.
He's really friendly.
And in fact,
immediately after this,
I'm going to go have
drinks with him.
He called me a lot,
because he really wanted
to stay true to the novel.
And then he sent revs
of the screenplay,
and got my feedback on it.
He made some changes based
on one on my feedback,
and ignored other
things, which fine.
It's his screenplay.
And then, while they
were filming it,
I would get these
questions filtered
through four intermediaries
from Ridley Scott.
And I could tell
from the questions
that he was asking
that he really
cared about technical
and scientific accuracy.
I mean one of the questions
that came through was,
he said, OK, can we show
Mark pouring hydrazine
from one container into another,
out on the surface of Mars.
He's wearing his
EVA suit and he's
pouring it from one
container to the other.
And I'm like, no, hydrazine
is really volatile
and in Mars atmospheric
pressure it would boil off.
And he's like, OK, then
we're not going to do it.
And so it's that level of
technical double checking, led
me to believe, OK, they're
really being accurate.
And then, of course, a few
days ago I saw the movie
and I'm like, ooh!
It's really good.
Although the version I saw
it's funny-- the version I saw,
they're still adding
in special effects.
So there's some really cheesy
roughed in visual effects
right now.
Oh look, a grainy JPEG of
Mars in the background, that's
awesome.
And the Zero G
scenes, they still
have the wires holding the
actors and actresses up
as they float around.
And it's funny, but it's--
that's all going to be taking
care of.
Oh, and a lot of scenes
on Mars, It's like, look,
oh look it's Mars, and
there's some Martian plants
and shrubbery.
Oh, these must be some
native Martian tire tracks.
And I see a couple
of Martian pickup
trucks in the background.
So it's really funny to watch
the test screening versions,
because the CGI is just
about the last thing they do.
Because they rough everything
in, and then they look,
they view it over
and over again,
they do test screenings
and everything.
And only when they know the
exact sequence of scenes,
when they have the
editing complete,
are they willing to
commit to the CGI.
So there are parts of the
movie where they're like, yes,
definitely this is going to be
in, go ahead and work on it.
But if you waste
a second of CGI,
if you have your effects
department make one second
of CGI that you later
cut from the film,
you've just pissed
away $100, 000.
So they really care
about that, which
is why the CGI is so rough.
So, let's see I though
there's one other--
I thought there was
something else, but I'm old
and I'm senile.
So I forgot.
So anyway, that's the
end of my little spiel.
So now I'm going
to take questions.
And if anybody has
questions, they're
going to set that microphone up.
This lovely lady here
is setting it up.
And anybody who wants ask
a question just walk on up.
AUDIENCE: First off.
Where are we having drinks
with Drew after the--
ANDY WEIR: It's at ah--
AUDIENCE: And the
second question
is, when you went
for the movie rights
at the same time
as the book rights,
I never even heard that before.
Is that unique?
ANDY WEIR: I think so.
It's kind of unique to the new
world of-- to self publishing.
Self publishing and, well,
the internet in general
has really turned the
publishing industry on its ear.
There's no longer
an old boy network
between you and the reader.
So people can
easily self publish.
Now that doesn't mean you
get a pretty bad signal
to noise ratio.
If you look out-- if you
look through Kindle and say,
what's available
in self publishing.
Well, there's about a million
books, and most of them suck.
But that's where-- that's where
rating systems, like Barnes
and Noble and Amazon have,
come in really handy.
Kind of drifting off topic.
But the point is self
publishing causes people
to be, what do you call it,
popular successes before they
have business deals.
So this sort of thing will
happen if you do that.
"Martian" is one case.
"Wool" by Hugh Howey, I
don't know if any of you've
read that.
That's another case of a self
published novel going big.
And, of course,
I'm sure all of you
are huge fans of
"Fifty Shades of Gray."
Because you all look
like you're into that.
Yeah, but that
is-- whether or not
you like it or
consider it trash,
it is a self publishing success.
That also, like in
all these cases,
the book and movie rights
came very close together.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: When you started
putting together all these--
signing your rights away,
did they make you do anything
with your website?
Like take down the
text of the book?
ANDY WEIR: Yup.
AUDIENCE: Or make it not
suck or anything like that?
ANDY WEIR: Yup, it turns
out they don't like it
when you give things away for
free that they're selling.
So they said, well, I
mean conceptually I sold
the rights to Random House.
So I no longer have the legal
ability to distribute it.
Right.
And so they said,
yes, please we'd
like you to take that down.
So, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Do you still
have other works there?
ANDY WEIR: Oh sure.
All the other stuff.
Anything that-- everything
except for "The Martian".
And my next book is going to be
"Zhek', tentative title "Zhek."
And it's-- it's a more
traditional sci-fi.
It's got aliens, and
faster than light travel,
and stuff like that.
And I had been posting
that as a serial also.
Around the same time
as "The Martian."
And now the Random House
bought the rights to that,
and I'm working on
that as my next book,
they had me take that down too.
But everything else on my site.
AUDIENCE: So hi Andy.
ANDY WEIR: Hi.
AUDIENCE: I know that you--
when you wrote the book you
got a lot of feedback from
readers of your website.
And later on from
members of the space
community on technical
accuracy and so on.
You were able to
smooth all that out.
However, I noticed
reading the book,
you also really got a
lot right in the sort
of NASA political
world, in the way
that things kind of-- people
interacted back on Earth
and that kind of thing.
I wondered if you also got
some feedback from the space
community about those things,
and how those would work.
And if you make any
changes to reflect that,
or if you just got lucky and
got it right on the first shot.
ANDY WEIR: Well,
so, first off, I
didn't know anyone in aerospace
when I wrote the book.
So I didn't have any sources.
I just actually-- I say this
every time, but this is true.
My primary form of
research was Google.
Just-- and about 90% of
the things I looked up
took me straight to Wikipedia.
So, I didn't have any feedback
from NASA folks or anything
like that, at the
time I wrote it.
But later on, after--
afterward they did come back
and say, yes.
The way you describe
the politics
in NASA and the way things
work are absolutely correct.
One thing that was awesome about
this whole experience for me
is that NASA invited me out
to the Johnson Space Center
for four days of VIP tours.
And I got to look at
all sorts of cool stuff.
And my favorite
part of it was I got
to go into the mission
control center for ISS.
Into, not just an
observation area, but into.
And I got to sit at one of the
stations and remote control
a camera on the outside of ISS.
It was very cool.
But I got to talk to
Dr. Ellen Ochoa, who
is a two time astronaut and
the current Director of Johnson
Space Center.
So she answers to the
administer of NASA.
That's her rank.
And she was telling
me, she said,
for every NASA
character in your book
I can tell you a real person
who is exactly like that.
And so that was pretty cool.
How did I get it right?
Well, I mentioned earlier on
I worked for Sandia National
Labs, back when I was 15.
And I did that all
through high school.
And Sandia National Labs is a
big federally funded research
facility.
And, so, I didn't know anything
about the internals of NASA,
so I just assumed-- I just
said, well, big federally funded
research facility, big federally
funded research facility.
I'm just going to use the
politics that I saw at Sandia
as being the politics at NASA.
Turns out it was correct.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, spot on.
ANDY WEIR: I think
you worked for NASA?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
ANDY WEIR: Oh.
Cool.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I always wondered, what is
the ratio between the end
product of a book and
the background material,
and the research material
that you collect and compose
in the mean time.
The background stories,
the maps, the whatever,
they don't make their
way into the book,
but you need them to make
everything feel real.
ANDY WEIR: Right.
Well, sometimes I
do a lot of content
without requiring
any research at all.
And other times I did do
huge amounts of research
just to get a tiny
bit of content.
And it was really frustrating,
because I would be like,
oh I did all this research.
It took me a week
to figure this out,
and it's going to be one
sentence in the book.
I'm like, no, it took me
a long time to write this.
It should take you a
long time to read it.
But you've gotta resist
that urge to overdo it
and show your work.
One thing I did was
I wrote software
to calculate the
orbital trajectories
that they take on their
ship from Earth to Mars.
Those are all real.
And it was hard,
because I kind of have
an interest in normal dynamics.
It's actually
really simple math.
It's not really complicated.
But it gets insanely
complicated when
you have a ship that
constantly accelerates.
So their ship uses
ion propulsion.
So it has a very slow constant
acceleration of two millimeters
per second per second.
That's it, but it can do
it constantly for months.
And so once I was
about 10 integrals in,
in my gigantic page full
of formulas, You know what?
I'm not going to
work out this way.
But I'm a computer programmer.
So when the only tool
you have is a hammer,
every problem starts
to look like a nail.
And, so, I'm going to do
this through brute force
and simulation.
So I wrote software to work it
out and try different things,
until I found the
course that they would
take to get from Earth to Mars.
Which also required
me to choose a launch
window that would work.
And I had the
additional limitation
of the launch window
had to work such
that, while they were on Mars,
Thanksgiving of that year
would happen.
During that period.
For plot reasons, I needed that.
And, so, OK, I need to calculate
a constantly accelerating
orbital trajectory that gets to
Mars such that within 31 days
there'll be Thanksgiving.
And it has to happen at
least 20 years in the future
to be plausible, and I don't
want me to far in the future.
Anyway July 7, 2035.
Anyway, so, I would say I spent
at least half to 3/4 of my time
doing research.
AUDIENCE: So, no you
have these huge books
somewhere at home that has
all this stuff that you--
ANDY WEIR: Yeah.
I have a file called stuff,
and a file called notes,
and a file called ENPO, which
is a thing I do for every story.
It stands for events,
no particular order.
And with just all my
crap, and all my thoughts,
and all my math,
and stuff like that.
And spreadsheets galore.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi Andy.
I was wondering about your
thoughts for in our world.
What you think the future
holds or space exploration.
Whether we will be able to
have a mission like the Aries
missions in our lifetimes?
If we'll move beyond that?
And just your thoughts
on the future.
ANDY WEIR: Sure.
Well, first off unlike--
so the Aries mission as
predicted-- as put in
the book, not predicted.
[LAUGHTER]
ANDY WEIR: No.
The ARES mission in
the book, remember.
So first off, I should be clear.
The only reason I
write is to entertain.
I never have a point.
I never have a moral.
I never want to do anything
but make the reader go, "cool!"
And that's it.
So there's no-- I'm
not pushing any agenda.
And, so, with that
mind the Ares mission
was made to entertain people.
Not-- it's not
necessarily my idea
of how a Mars mission
will probably work.
I did it deliberately to evoke
those feelings of the Apollo
era.
And that excitement that every
reader-- everybody in the world
has some sense, some connection
with the Apollo program,
even if you were
born way afterward.
And so this rather
shamelessly and cheesily
pulled on those heart strings.
Realistically, I think
a manned mission to Mars
would be a large international
effort, like the International
Space Station.
I think it'd be us, European
Space Agency, the Russians,
maybe even the
Chinese, JAXA for sure.
And it'll be this big
complicated space station
basically that
they send to Mars.
And it'll be like that.
So that's my prediction for how
a manned Mars mission will go.
And I also think that-- NASA
says they can do it by 2035.
I believe they could if
they got enough funding,
but I don't think they'll
get enough funding.
I predict more on
the order of 2050ish.
That's my guess.
And then your other
question is, what do I
feel about the future
space exploration.
I think we're right at the
cusp of an awesome era,
because now we're
finally starting
to look at it from a commercial
and economic sense, instead
of just a flags and
footprints kind of thing.
And, so, we've got
companies like SpaceX
driving the price down.
I think the absolute
key to space exploration
is driving the price down to get
a mass in the low earth orbit.
Once you do that a commercial
industry will naturally evolve.
And if you don't believe
me, let me ask you this.
All of you, your engineers
mostly, probably, right?
And, so, you make decent income,
but you're not billionaires,
right?
Would you pay $100,000
to spend a week in space?
Raise your hand if you
would pay $100,000 to spend
a week in a space hotel.
All right.
So this is about 30% of the
population of this room.
If you could make it such that
middle class Americans could
afford, as a once
in a lifetime event,
to go into space for a week, you
would have effectively infinite
demand.
And then that's
when companies would
start to come in, and
figure out the technology
necessary to drive the price
down further and further
and compete with each other.
So it all starts with companies
like SpaceX and Boeing,
and the commercial
programs that NASA's doing.
And I think we're on our way.
So I think it's going
to be pretty awesome.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ANDY WEIR: Sure.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thanks for coming to Google.
ANDY WEIR: Thanks for having me.
AUDIENCE: So you
talked a little bit
about how you were
researching the science
aspect of your books.
I'm curious about your
process for the plot
and the characters.
Do you have them in
your head ahead of time?
Or do they kind of
appear as you write?
How much rewriting do you do?
I'm really curious about
that kind of stuff.
ANDY WEIR: The characters did
just kind appear as needed.
So, it's-- a lot
of people ask me,
why did you make
Commander Lewis a woman?
Or are you pushing-- are you
trying to show empowered women?
I'm like, no.
I thought, I need a
commander and my brain
came back with Commander Lewis.
I don't know why
she's a woman anymore
than I know why you know the
director of NASA's a man.
It's just, OK, thanks brain.
So I just pretty much
made them as I went along.
When I did rewrites I didn't
change any of the characters
at all.
I did sharpen their
personalities a bit,
especially the NASA people.
Because they tend to,
in the earlier revs
and probably even still, they
tended to blend together,
and you're like wait, which
one is this guy, which
one is that guy.
And so I give them
all personality quirks
to try to make them more severe,
but that was fine tuning.
As for rewrites, I
didn't really go off
on too many tangents that had
to be backed out and redone.
I tend to think
things-- it worked out.
"The Martian" went
really smoothly.
I'm learning that was
abnormally smoothly,
because I'm working
on my next book now
and I'm just screwing
up all the time.
I'm going off-- I
mean I just recently
deleted about 25,000
words of the book I'm
working on now, to go back
and do a different line.
So the answer to the question
is, on "The Martian" no,
but in general apparently yes,
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So I'll ask what I
think is a give me question.
But, suppose that
you were-- you were
going to be stranded on Mars.
You Andy Weir were
are going to be
stranded on Mars with basically
the stuff that Mark Watney has.
But you get to pick
where on Mars you're
going to be stranded.
Where would you want
to be stranded on Mars,
to survive the longest, to
get back, that kind of thing.
Where's the best place for you,
as far as you're concerned?
ANDY WEIR: Well, that sucks.
AUDIENCE: No, that
would be awesome.
ANDY WEIR: What's that?
AUDIENCE: I said that
would be awesome.
But I don't want to
interfere with your answers.
ANDY WEIR: Well,
I guess I'd want
to be somewhere that had
a decent amount of water
in the soil.
So one fun thing that
happened is in the book,
we see this huge long process
that the protagonist has
to go through to create water.
He reduces hydrazine to
liberate hydrogen out of it.
He collects carbon dioxide
from Mars' atmosphere,
runs it through the-- runs
it through HAB's oxygenator
to liberate the oxygen. Takes
the hydrogen and oxygen,
burns them together
to generate water.
Screws add up.
Blows himself up a little bit.
It's interesting.
And then, after I
finished "The Martian,"
they landed the Curiosity
probe on Mars in real life.
And the Curiosity
probe went scoop,
hey there's a shit
load of water here.
Turns out for every cubic
meter of Martian soil,
there's 35 liters
of water in it.
So all Mark had to do was
get some dirt and heat it up.
But I didnt' know that.
So I get away with one thing.
What I do is say,
well, Curiosity
is in Gale Crater right now, at
the base of Mount Sharp, which
is 5,000 or 6,000
kilometers away from where
"The Martian" takes place
in [? Assideliaplonessia. ?]
So I could say well Mars
is not one universal thing.
I'm saying
[? Assideliaplonessia ?]
is a desert, and it doesn't
have a lot of water.
And yet can't prove me
wrong until somebody
sends a probe there.
So I guess, I would want a
place that has a lot of water.
So Gale Crater we know
for a fact has water.
That is handy because if you
have water, you have hydrogen.
And that is a really
critical element.
AUDIENCE: You'd also have to get
the percholorates out though.
ANDY WEIR: Yes and I have-- I've
heard all sorts of conflicting
crap about perchlorates.
I get people-- I get
some people telling me.
So for those who don't know.
For those of you who don't know
the details of Martian soil
sciences.
Martian soil has a
lot of perchlorates.
And perchlorates they
don't prevent plant growth,
but they can make the plants
that you grow poisonous.
Or so I'm told.
I get conflicting
reports on that.
Some people tell me, oh no, if
you grow plants in Martian soil
without clearing out
the perchlorates,
your bone-- those
plants are bad for you.
Other people are like, yeah it's
bad for you, but so is smoking.
And it's not as bad
for you as starving.
So I get conflicting
reports on that.
In an emergency situation.
I think the perchlorates
aren't that big a deal.
But you wouldn't want to
found a colony based on this.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Aside from
the apparent new
found understanding of
the abundance of water
on Mars, aside
from that, what do
you think is the least plausible
scene or series evens--
sequence of events
in the Martian?
ANDY WEIR: OK there are few.
So--
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: The least plausible.
They're all very implausible.
ANDY WEIR: Yeah.
Well.
OK, so there are two
places where I deliberately
violated physics in
reality for plot purposes.
Number one, the biggest one is
the sandstorm at the beginning.
In reality Mars' atmosphere
is 0.6% as in about one two
hundredth, the density
of Earth's atmosphere.
So it's extremely,
extremely thin.
And yes they do get
sandstorms on-- they.
You know those Martians.
Mars does get sandstorms
150 kilometers an hour.
But with the air so thin the
inertia of the sandstorms
is extremely low.
It's like being in about
one kilometer an hour
breeze on earth.
It wouldn't knock over anything.
It wouldn't damage anything.
It wouldn't hurt anything.
I came up with an alternate
scenario in the story
where it turns out, oh, OK--
I had it where they're doing
and MAV engine test.
And there's an explosion
during that process.
And that's what causes
all the problems.
And I had ways to force
them to the lift off.
And think Mark was dead,
and all that stuff.
But it just didn't feel
right, it didn't feel as good.
And in a man versus
nature story,
I wanted nature to get
the first punch in.
And, so it worked out
for the 99.9% of people
who don't know about the
realities of Mara' atmosphere,
there's a real
general public idea
that Martian dust
storms are this--
are like Earth sandstorms.
So I played into that.
The other deliberate thing
I did was-- the violation
of the reality I did was, I
just have this one paragraph
somewhere in the middle of the
book where he says, oh, yeah,
the HABs, and the
rovers, and EVA suits
are all radiation shielded.
OK.
There's no such material
that can do that,
that casually or that easily.
He has this thin, flexible,
airtight material,
it's about that thick that
will block all the radiation,
or brings the radiation
levels inside the HAB down
to Earth normal.
And you just can't do that.
You would actually need
several centimeters of lead,
or 10 centimeters of
water, or a meter of rock
to get the radiation
levels down to what we
have on the surface of Earth.
Because Earth has a big
strong magnetic field and also
a big thick atmosphere
to stop the radiation
from getting to us.
And Mars has neither.
So that was another
thing that I didn't
want to deal with,
because I knew
he was going to be
out on the surface
doing all these makeshift
solutions, lots of stuff.
And I didn't want
to say, oh, yeah
and then he dies of cancer.
So-- so that was
some hand wavy stuff.
So some things I
got wrong by mistake
are the water thing that
I just talked about.
And then one of them is really,
really obscure, but I liked it.
A chemist emailed me after
the book was out in print,
so I couldn't change anything.
He's like, OK, you told
me how much hydrazine Mark
reduced in the HAB.
You told me how much and
how long he took to do it.
You gave information
elsewhere in the book
about the internal
volume of a HAB,
and what the atmospheric
makeup is of the HAB.
And so this gives me
enough information
to calculate how much the
temperature inside the HAB
is going to go up,
do that chemistry.
It's 400 degrees Celsius.
I could have solved
that one pretty easily,
if I'd known about it.
But anyway, so those are
the few the inaccuracies.
But, I think, you're asking
what is the biggest inaccuracy?
The biggest inaccuracy is that
a mission that size would get
funded at all.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: So, one more.
This isn't particularly--
I don't particularly
have a well formed
question around this.
It's just one thing that kept
striking me over and over as I
was reading the book is this
is a man versus nature story,
as you were just alluding to.
And those are really
all that common.
You see a lot more
inter-personal conflicts,
man versus man or whatever, in
terms of these gross categories
of stories.
Is this-- I guess
my question would
be, is this kind of your
favorite sort of thing
to write?
Did you find this
to be fruitful?
Just what was your feeling on
writing that kind of story?
ANDY WEIR: I really enjoyed it.
And I do love man
versus nature stories.
Because it's really just a
veiled way of saying science!
Right.
Because that's what man versus
nature really is, right.
I mean-- and the
other thing I like
about it is, I don't
know about other people,
but when I'm watching a story
with a central plot conflict,
with a protagonist
and an antagonist.
A part of me, no matter,
how bad he is, a part of me
roots for the antagonist.
Because first off I know
that in almost all stories
the antagonist is
destined to fail.
And so I kind of
feel sorry for him.
And I'm rooting for him.
Also usually the antagonist
is the prime mover.
The antagonist is, I'm the
villain who's robbing the bank,
or I'm the guy who's threatening
earth with my death ray,
or something.
He's the one who's
making the plot happen.
He's generally the most
interesting character
in the story.
And you feel kind
of conflicted when
you're reading the stories,
or watching a movie,
or whatever, because
you're like, ah,
well now this hero is going to
come in and ruin everything.
Right.
And in a man versus nature
there's no divided loyalties.
Nobody roots for nature
in man versus nature.
It's like, I hope
that guy drowns.
And so, it's nice.
And, also, it plays into this
kind of Pollyanna optimism
that I have in-- this
really is my world view.
I really think humanity is good.
Despite how-- despite
what you see in the news.
I really feel humanity
is good and it
makes me feel good to see
a bunch of people working
together to help each other.
And not a bunch of people
in a war working together
to kill a bunch of other people.
But, OK, we're all
going to do this.
So that's why it's, yeah,
there are bad people
and they do bad things.
But the people who do good
things greatly outnumber them.
And they don't make the news,
because it's just presumed
as part of human nature.
And so the quote I always say
is, 19 people made 9/11 happen,
but thousands of people
rushed in to help.
So that's my view on
the nature of humanity.
AUDIENCE: Awesome.
Thanks very much.
ANDY WEIR: Sure.
OK.
AUDIENCE: Hi Andy.
I'm Abbey.
Nice to meet you.
Thanks for coming.
First of all, I want to
give a shout out to-- you
actually have your marketing
team whose working with FOX
to help market your movie here.
ANDY WEIR: Oh, great.
AUDIENCE: So, Everyone's
here to help you.
ANDY WEIR: Hello
AUDIENCE: But I also
I want to ask you,
obviously this is like
a life changing thing--
ANDY WEIR: Nah.
AUDIENCE: You were putting
something on the website,
and you have a
movie about a book.
And as someone who want to be
a writer, that probably nice.
ANDY WEIR: It is really nice.
AUDIENCE: Are you
transitioning now
into being a full time author.
Or are you still doing
the computer programming?
ANDY WEIR: I quit my day job.
I'm working full
time as a writer now.
I quit my day job
back, last April.
And it was kind of bitter
sweet, because it wasn't a
take this job and
shove it situation.
I liked my job.
I worked for a company
called MobileIron, where
I did Android programming.
And I really liked it.
I liked my coworkers.
I liked my team, my boss.
People respected me there.
And everybody was rooting
for me on the book stuff.
As they were all
watching this happen.
And they're, yeah, yeah go.
And they knew I was
a flight risk as seen
as a book started
to be-- But I still
love computer programming.
In fact, I have to not do it.
Because if I start a side
project, just some little fun
thing on the side, a game
or something like that,
I know I'll work on
that instead of writing.
And that's dangerous.
AUDIENCE: Well, how did
you find the balance
when you were doing
work and writing?
Obviously one's-- their
both fueled our passion,
so you make time for that, but--
ANDY WEIR: Part of
it that really helps
a lot is to not have a life.
And, so, after work I'm at home.
[LAUGHTER]
So, and I don't know.
It's just-- the main thing
that motivated me and made
it a priority for
me was releasing
it chapter by chapter.
I got feedback and
just constant reminders
that people really
were reading it.
Every time I'd
release a chapter,
I'd get hundreds of emails
of people with feedback.
And it just went, OK,
people are reading my stuff.
And I think that's--
almost no writter--
almost every writer
is driven by that.
Not driven by like, I
want to make some money.
I mean some of them are I guess.
But the vast majority
of us are just like,
people are reading this book.
I created of a fictional world.
And other people are
enjoying it and I love that.
And so that'll help motivate me.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ANDY WEIR: Thank you.
Is that it?
OK.
AUDIENCE: Let's extend
a thank you to Andy.
ANDY WEIR: Thank you.